[Music]
elon musk
seriously considering creating a new
social media company based around true
free speech i hope he does it
what is it going to be like youtube a
lot of people true free speech to you
twitter needs competition as hell no
question about him does anybody even
disagree with that on any spectrum is
twitter used to be with jack dorsey it
used to be the place where you could say
what are the [ __ ] you stepped down right
yeah yeah something weird happened for
sure it was like a change it's a very
very unique time right now and it's
actually because of twitter that uh our
tech billionaire elon musk started
seriously considering this was he being
censored uh him specifically i don't
think so but uh he's revealed that he's
giving serious thoughts to building a
brand new social media platform he
shared his thoughts on twitter after
criticizing the platform for not
sticking to the principle of free speech
and he said or tweeted
given that twitter serves as the de
facto public town square failing to
adhere to free speech principles
fundamentally undermines democracy what
should be done
and that's actually a response to his
own tweet earlier that said free speech
is essential to a functioning democracy
do you believe twitter rigorously
adheres to this principle i love
responding to your own tweet first of
all pretty much and what's funny is that
um
i mean they they you could have [ __ ]
all over twitter
but then if you say something
that they don't agree with
yeah they just block your ass and i'm
like that's [ __ ] crazy dude there was
this one thing this this [ __ ] viral
thing that was going on where girls
would
they would put their phone up like this
and they would run up to their bed and
slam their [ __ ] up oh yeah
it's crazy the athleticism that's
required to like jump up and spread your
legs
and then the [ __ ] just flies into the
screen for real
who put a stop to this yeah who started
a challenge it was a great challenge we
started that's a really good challenge
feel like joe started this challenge i
wish i could first of all men started
this challenge dude
men started this challenge this is like
guys that they're dead
no but it was like nudity though oh yeah
yeah
because it's uncensored rainbow parties
and i was like a guy came up with this
[ __ ] dude explain to the viewers what
rainbow okay so rainbow party is when um
oh wait i know
there's a bunch of women at a party and
they all put on different lipstick and
then they take turns blowing a guy
to see
who can go deeper on the dick i think am
i crazy i thought it was just to make it
like a barber shop make it look like a
bunch of lifesavers right
so it's like fruit stripe gum
rainbow party yeah but i'm like a man
came up with this bro i'm like a
rockefeller came up with rockefeller you
hefner came up with this right
a boy who looked at those hills and saw
opportunity
but yeah i mean give me a break
the politicians were talking about that
like it was an epidemic that everyone's
[ __ ] doing this like bill o'reilly's
on there every night he's like well they
got the rainbow parties now and i'm like
bill you [ __ ] wish
you wish i'm gonna touch you this
happened twice
what happened with that one um
that trump was making he wanted to do
truths truth social did anyone go on it
[ __ ] like there was also what was
that other one it was sig not so was it
signal club yeah i heard it i've heard
yeah like there's some like other like
social medias that we're just like oh
cause i remember on instagram like a lot
of people that i follow were like oh
like
instagram isn't friendly to like pro gun
content or like american content so
we're gonna like [ __ ] leave and i'm
like cool i'll see you in like two weeks
bro
and then they came back and i'm just
like yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ] bro cause it's
like no one's going on or yeah whatever
other stupid social media they're
bringing like oh that's gonna have free
speech so he's free to drive i hide a
clubhouse while you're over there you
get a good luck house by the way you
guys hop on clubhouse i did and it
petered out like immediately yeah yeah
it was done in 60 days yeah yeah so yeah
good [ __ ] luck dude
trump decided to launch his own social
media empire when he was banned from the
likes of facebook and twitter there's a
raft of other sites following his
comments after the 2020 u.s election and
for being accused of inciting the
violence at the capitol insurrection
so when he announced the idea in october
of last year he said i created truth
social and tmtg to stand up for the
tyranny of big tech we live in a world
where the taliban has a huge presence on
twitter yet your favorite american
president has been silenced this is
unacceptable but also not not false
right like
yeah he used band but the taliban's
there i know he's banned but like
taliban has an account hey right putin
was there until what two weeks ago or
some [ __ ] it's crazy
that's after he started the world do you
think he made a comment about pizza
though
he went after
[Laughter]
who here like really [ __ ] with elon
musk though i love you like
a lot of my business friends hate him
well here's the thing i don't like all
his like what he did last may with
crypto stuff that was clear manipulation
[ __ ] but like on the whole i like what
he's about yeah yeah
i want to believe he's a good guy
i want to believe that i would sign up
for his social media i would too yeah
for sure i like him on the sole fact
that he is a great marketer and a troll
but yeah that's all what if they just
give blue check marks only to people
that have teslas i'd buy a tesla oh it's
really smart there's no there's no
brilliant he's just a marketer and a
troll he didn't like i don't know he's a
genius uh marketer and a troll oh i
think that's genius mark okay
you know he's got like a space company
and nearly
you know changing the world through like
the automotive like you know what's
funny about that though uh i think
because maybe i'm too small brained i
like him best for the blowtorch the
boring company like all the boring
company [ __ ] the best it's my favorite
[ __ ] i also like him for that what he
did with the rocketry is really cool
seeing a rocket like land on its dick is
really funny
but but watching like like him come out
with a flamethrower and then try to
figure out how to sell it to people and
stuff i loved all that the best was
being like hey this cyber truck
bulletproof and then they just shattered
stuff
but dude everybody talked about the
cyber truck after that yeah yeah every
it's a household name everybody knows
what the cyber yeah when are the cyber
tracks going on it doesn't matter the
fact that it exists in your mind wait
did the atvs come out yet uh the kids
ones the kids ones did
like so power wheels i want to play that
lives rent free in your head isn't that
think about it for sure though that's
the beginning of new york honestly he's
a genius bro he's a genius he's he's
operating on a different wavelength that
most people are just like well this
guy's an idiot the wavelength is
asperger's exactly and it's a great
wavelength well andy's good at marketing
and he's good at the meme culture right
like he charges 69 420 for [ __ ] yeah
it's great love all that he named his
car sexy he put the car in space for no
[ __ ] reason yeah and i'm sure it
pissed off somebody out there who's like
why is a car polluting space it's like
space is really big
we can afford it i think we'll be fine
if we can pollute anything it's going to
be spanish yeah guess what somebody's
really polluted already you'll be fine
it's like throwing a cell in the ocean
dude
what are you doing a cell in the ocean
that's like the cell phone in the ocean
don't do that don't do that
blackberry
just like dumping my motor oil into the
ocean there's a lot of water
it'll be gone on a little bit doesn't
even mix
yeah look it stays separate
i'm in a biological cell but we could go
with telephone too if you want
yeah they're both liquids
good save good save good really good
save i mean this guy really took the
[ __ ] twitter and he said free speech
is essential to a function of democracy
do you believe twitter rigorously and
here's this principle and they put a
poll out and he's got 79 million
followers and 70 of people said no
twitter does not
like that's pretty huge and then he says
is a new platform needed and then 328
000 people liked it so far and obviously
those people are more likely to agree
with him so that's that's easier right
yeah sway that but
what i like about elon is you know once
again the marketing thing like i'm not a
billionaire i hope to be someday
and if i am on your way i promise you on
my name on my good name
the first thing that i do
is i construct the world's largest dildo
not even kidding the world's biggest
[ __ ] dildo ever
in space because it's so big bro you
can't even build it here it's like it's
like star trek i have to build this [ __ ]
in space okay so you know what i the
first you know what i do with it the
first thing i do with it
i sent it to a crater in the moon so
that it [ __ ] its [ __ ] that crater in
the moon
so you can see it with a space telescope
i would want to rock it any kid in their
backyard any little any anybody in the
backyard can see that dildo [ __ ] the
moon so austin powers yeah what will the
hat will they say your name on it steve
green
i should have thought of that i didn't
think of that that's why i need you
to join i made it are you talking about
this company
do you like the idea of a rocket though
like a veiny dick rocket because you
want to launch that [ __ ]
and then you see it hit the moon with
dude it hits the crater on the moon
the deepest crater but guess what that's
money well spent there love that i love
that this plan will probably knock the
moon out of orbit and like crash into
earth and kill everything on earth so be
it
for the vision
[Laughter]
not with this technology
i'm like hey if it if the moon really
does affect the oceans i guess we about
to find out
see how the tides are going all my flat
earth there's a little shout out
where are you all right this is a
cruciating slaughter this is this whole
time
[ __ ] the moon so hard which villain was
trying to steal the moon or some [ __ ]
like that despicable me
mr burns was trying to block the moon
yeah okay and then just trying to block
the sun you guys do you guys remember
when china was trying to make their own
moon why do they got to do it we already
have a moon why do they gotta copy the
moon we got it dude do your own thing
you know the moon there's a there's
going to be a moon resort at vegas you
know that right what does that mean it's
like a [ __ ] sphere like it's a moon
like a bio dome it's a little [ __ ]
moon it's literally imagine a hotel but
it's a circle a sphere and then the
entire outside is [ __ ] led let's see
what we're talking about
yeah i remember they're building it
right now
there's going to be a moon resort
there's going to be a resort yeah that's
not that's the thing we saw from trump
tower yeah yeah no [ __ ] that's crazy
that's sick but i think it's led based
so they're going to like use they're
going to make it look like the moon at
night sometimes or turn it into a giant
[ __ ] visual so like resort world
it'll just be like running [ __ ] heads
hey jake from state farm here you know
by my [ __ ] state farm chris paul's in
it too yeah adriana's galactic insurance
coverage traveling off earth that sounds
like it's going to make sense in some
sort of [ __ ] futuristic like 2028 a
space odyssey you're like 10 years i'll
fight for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you